the presidency of the United States has
been so debased under Donald Trump that
it sort of become like a piece of gum
that you stepped on a few weeks ago like
it's a reality there's gum on the sole
of your shoe
every time you walk around with it it's
more and more covered in dirt and at
some point you're gonna have to deal
with it but maybe you'll just not put
that pair of shoes on for a while or
pretend that the gum isn't there so that
you can save yourself the annoyance of
having to deal with it but this is a
reality there's gum on your shoe and the
American presidency has become
completely debased and what the hell am
I talking about well this all relates to
Jamal khashoggi and Donald Trump's
increasingly unhinged and erratic and
dishonest perspective which is providing
more and more cover to the Saudi royal
family which we've been told now by the
CIA was directly involved that Saudi
Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman
specifically ordered the killing of
journalist Jamal khashoggi in Istanbul
Turkey and we're gonna get to trump in a
second but first just to kind of catch
you up Jamal Khashoggi a journalist
working for The Washington Post an
American resident not an American
citizen went to the Saudi embassy in
Istanbul at the Saudi consulate in
Istanbul Turkey to deal with some
paperwork related to a marriage related
thing that he had to do was killed there
and then we received multiple
contradictory explanations from the
Saudis it's hard to even remember all of
them I think at first the Saudi said we
have no idea we have no clue nothing
happened at the consulate itself second
story was well khashoggi did go to the
consulate but he left very quickly and
if he was killed it certainly had
nothing to do with anything that
happened at the consulate the third
story was one that was actually fed to
Donald Trump which is okay he did die
and we know he died but it could have
been anybody including rogue killers the
fourth story was he died in an
interrogation gone wrong the fifth story
was he actually showed up and started a
fight
at the consulate why a 60-year old man
would start a fight with 15 people we
don't know and why that led to him dying
we also didn't know and eventually what
we learned is that 15 Saudi agents flew
to Turkey killed khashoggi inside the
consulate direct links between the
assassination and subsequent
dismemberment to the Saudi royal royal
family the CIA says they have a bunch of
evidence this includes phone calls
documents much more and the CIA also
explained that even without the specific
evidence that they have it would have
been very reasonable to believe that the
crown prince was involved because we
know he's involved in everything in
Saudi Arabia down to the micro but in
this case we also have intelligence and
documents that tells us what went on so
then we get to trump trump and response
has said that he was both fully briefed
and not yet briefed but either way he
was very strongly told by the Saudi
Crown Prince that he wasn't involved and
had absolutely nothing to do with it but
he's also not going to be listening to
the audio tape of the incident because
it is quote a suffering tape let's talk
through it because it's so absurd first
example Trump asked about about this
over the weekend standing outside the
White House gives an answer that
suggests that he simply has no idea
about anything but he's going to look
into it again with the helicopter
blaring in the background and he opted
to not say that he believes any of what
was known at the time but instead
praised Saudi Arabia take a listen to
this but we haven't been briefed yet the
CIA is going to be speaking me to me
today we have not been briefed yet as of
this moment we were told that he did not
play a role we're gonna have to find out
what they have to say
taking a look at it you know we also
have a great ally in Saudi Arabia they
give us a lot of jobs they give us a lot
of business a lot of Economic
Development they are they have been a
truly spectacular ally in terms of jobs
and economic development
so then Crump asks is asked again later
on in the weekend okay so were you
briefed have you listened to the
recording that is part of the evidence
now and Trump says no and I'm not going
to listen to the tape take a listen to
him talking to Chris Wallace on Fox News
Sunday Turkish president air Dewan says
that he has shared a tape with the US
and other countries that is of the
killing of Jamal khashoggi inside the
Saudi consulate in Istanbul have you one
either heard the tape yourself or been
briefed on it and if so to your mind
what does it show we have the tape I
don't want to hear the tape no reason
for me to hear the tape why don't what
I've been probably gonna hear it sir
because it's a suffering tape it's a
terrible tape I've been fully briefed on
it there's no reason for me to hear it
in fact I said to the people should I
they said you really shouldn't there's
no reason I know exactly I know
everything that went on the tank where
that happened and what happened it was
very violent very vicious and terrible
the president of the US simply refusing
to check out the evidence we have for a
horrific murder committed by one of our
allies because he doesn't want to hear
the suffering and you know what at least
the guys admitting that the tape exists
that alone could be considered a victory
in the climate of lies and deception
that we're dealing with and then after
claiming to have been briefed and not to
have been briefed here's the key to this
entire thing a month ago you said you
had spoken with Saudi Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman and that he had told
you directly that he had no knowledge
and still says that but we now know that
some of the people closest to him some
of his closest advisers were part of
this question did NBS lie to you sir
I don't I don't know you know who can
really know but I can say this he's got
many people now that say he had no
knowledge what if the crown prince
speaking to you the President of the
United States directly lied to you well
that he told me that he had nothing to
do with it he told me that I would say
maybe five times at different points
what if his laws recently as a few days
ago do you just live with it because you
need him well will anybody really know
all right will anybody really know but
he did have certainly people that were
reasonably close to him and close to him
that were probably involved you so we
put on very heavy sanctions massive
sanctions on a large group of people
from Saudi Arabia but at the same time
that's do have an ally and I want to
stick with an ally that in many ways has
been very good that's it that's all you
need to hear the facts are unknowable
will we ever really know and hey this is
an ally that is good for us do not allow
yourself to be sort of hypnotized or
lulled into thinking this is no big deal
a permanent resident of the u.s. working
as a journalist for The Washington Post
was murdered in a terrorist attack on
foreign soil by one of our allies
dismembered by one of our allies and
Donald Trump allows them they decide
what he thinks this is one of the
weakest most bata reactions to terror
that a president could have and you know
Pat it's Canada and France and Germany
and the UK that are the problems but
Saudi Arabia and Russia are the
trustworthy political players despite
the fact that even to Trump they are
lying this guy is weak isn't he yeah I
think this story demonstrates two things
one Trump's disdain for the media the
fact that he won't back up a reporter
who was brutally killed and also it
admits the u.s. has long-standing ties
to Saudi Arabia which are unethical ties
and to go back to your bethe comments I
think that it is really beta that Trump
won't watch the video I mean most people
aren't going to want to sit through that
but it's kind of the job as president
you have to observe those types of
things like Barack Obama and Hillary
Clinton sitting in the Situation Room
watching the raid that took down Osama
bin Laden sometimes that's just part of
the job
yeah and Trump as we know picks and
chooses which parts of the job he wants
to do last thing on this watch for Jared
Kushner to have been much more involved
than we know because he is in very heavy
contact with the Saudi Crown Prince and
I would not would not be surprised if we
end up finding out more about his role
in this entire thing and I don't mean he
put an active participant role but
knowledge about what it was that was
going on one of today's sponsors is
privacy dot-com / Pakman this is a free
service that I've actually been using
myself for a while now and I love it you
just take a few seconds to link your
debit card or bank account to privacy
coms mobile app or browser extension for
Firefox and Chrome and what that does is
allow you to instantly create virtual
credit cards that are linked to your
bank account so that you're not actually
putting your real debit card number on
the internet and you use these virtual
credit card numbers to buy things online
and with one click of a button you have
the ability to create multiple virtual
cards delete cards freeze and unfreeze
cards you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5.00 towards your first purchase
when you sign up using that link below